now at 6 30.
the demand for food remains very high in
southern nevada and may go up
after mgm resorts international recently
announcing layoffs of
thousands of employees 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond shows us how
various agencies are trying to keep up
with the need
and adjusting to uncertain circumstances
not a hand out but a hand up anyone
who needs help and hope can come
catholic charities of southern nevada
keeps the door open to its food pantry
a place traditionally low-income
families come for assistance but
ceo deacon tom roberts says the need
extends
further now we've seen some additional
clients
from the resort industry adding to the
growing demand for food during the
pandemic
it's difficult to make predictions
because things seem to change very
quickly
but we're prepared to help as many as we
can and we want to help people
families can only pick up food from
catholic charities once a month
but the boxes they're receiving weigh
about 40 pounds each and have an
assortment of items
we want to continue to provide that gap
support as long as we can
also supporting the effort is three
square the food bank not only
assists pantry partners but continues
drive through distribution sites
and monitoring the steady rise in food
insecurity
it's now prolonged that it appears to be
something that we're going to have to
deal with for some time to come we are
in a situation
that is an unwritten crisis the las
vegas rescue mission hosts a produce
giveaway on thursdays
the program may expire soon though after
helping hundreds of people weekly
you should know mid next week whether
that's going to get extended
non-profits and others working to
address hunger in uncertain
circumstances
kristin drummond 8 news now and three
square does have a list of food
distribution sites and pantry partners
visit 8newsnow.com for a link and more
information